You're super echoey.
>> That's cuz you're also on the Zoom, but
we should be live now at this point. Um,
and then I'm going to leave the audio in
the Zoom and we should be live and good
to go. Awesome. And I'm going to post
the link over on our Discord as well.
And then we'll get started right away
with AI that works this topic.
>> Are you ready, Dex?
>> I'm ready. We're live.
>> All right. What's today's topic, Dex?
Give us the rundown. Uh so today's topic
we are going to talk about using coding
agents using bash versus MCP for tools
which has been a debate that's going on
uh a lot in a lot of places and I think
um
I want to just dig under the hood cuz
like most things in AI the answer is
there is no right answer and the correct
answer is to understand how the models
work under the hood understand how the
harnesses work under the hood And of
course do a little bit of context
engineering and really just understand
the tokens you're putting into the model
and taking out of the model model.
>> I think that's one of the topics that I
have been seeing happen more and more
over in um just popping up more and more
everywhere that I see right now. It's
happening over on like Twitter threads
all the time. I was just talking to a
user over on the uh
uh I was just talking to users over on
like the Discord and they were talking
about how UIDs cause like a huge problem
as well.
And it's just like all this stuff is
really just about simplicity. I don't
know if anyone's noticed Claude Code has
actually renamed their bash tool to
general purpose.
Like the words
>> that's the the task tool, right?
>> The general purpose tool that they added
recently and I think
>> I think that's the subtask agent. Yeah,
the word, but they renamed it. And I
think the reason for that is it's just a
better name. And a lot of people
underestimate how important these names
are.
And I think when we talk about MCP
versus Bash, I think that's the first
name we should talk about. Why don't we
why don't we start off with something
really basic, which is when we go start
off with this, I want to start off with
a whiteboard that really outlines how
MCP is actually working
uh under the hood. Yeah, exactly. Off
was me. I was just talking about this
like 60k tokens right in your context
window. I think the best analogy for
this is
um before we go really deep into it is
really going to be package management
software.
If anyone's ever built a website, you've
probably seen the extension that tells
you how big an npm import is that you're
making. And like there's some that are
like 65 megabytes and some that are
really small. And as of right now, I
think no one really cares if you use a
megabyte in your package. I mean, you
shouldn't. Please be nice and don't do
that. But in practicality, it doesn't
really matter uh on today's machines.
But like 12 months ago, uh 12 years ago,
it did matter. And I think that's kind
of the world we live in with MCPs versus
bash is like MCP in theory is really
nice. It's basically a packet man. It
says something for prompts is kind of
how I view it as. But the problem is if
you don't know what prompts are
happening under the hood, you're stuck
in this world where you made your
instead of making your website slower by
having a massive package, you've
accidentally made your um agent less
accurate by having a massive prompt. And
that's really the fundamental issue that
I think people run into. And like
slowness is kind of bad, but like you
can get around it because at least the
website functions the same. But accuracy
is not is is literally a user quality
hit. So I think that's why this
conversation is getting a lot of upbeat
more recently is because the accuracy
problem is effectively unbounded in
terms of difficulty.
>> Um yeah and so I want to jump right in.
Um we have a quick episode here. So, um,
when you launch a coding agent, and
we'll be talking about cloud today
because that's the one that, um, we have
the most experience with, but everything
we're doing is true for codeex, true for
AMP, true for open code, any CLI you
would use. Um, your context window and
your agents ability to do good work in
it. Um, is completely and directly
proportional to the size of your context
window. Um, I think we have Jeff Huntley
on stream today. I think the way he put
it is very clear and succinct. I don't
think anyone will argue with you. The
more context you use, the worse results
you will get across the board no matter
what. Um,
>> obviously having missing information or
incomplete information is bad, but um
the in general the more you can keep it
concise with the right information, the
better. Um, so when you launch a cloud
code prop and I'll show you kind of what
we'll look under the hood here actually.
Um, let's see. I'm actually going to
share my whole desktop. So um, add the
work circle of trust. If you see
something you shouldn't, please unsee it
and tell us.
>> Twitter deck, so we'll
>> Yeah, we're live on Twitter. Yeah.
>> Yeah, I'm not I'm not really I don't
trust any of you anymore. Sorry. We're
big we're big time now.
>> Um
so one thing that you uh that you can do
is you can look at a um you can we we
have this project here on AI that works.
Um, why does
Streamyard insist on hiding the stream
the window when it does full screen? Um,
so we uh all the code for this episode
is here. One of the things we've written
is a small reverse proxy that you can
run in Docker um that will just proxy
all your cloud traffic and then write it
out as log files. Um, I don't have the
log files here. Um,
or directly
and actually
>> you might have one of them over. Uh, I
think I saw you
>> in the other episode. Yeah, I didn't
push them.
>> For those of you that have haven't seen
the cloud code files, like when you
actually go look while Dex pulls it up,
some of the stuff that they add into the
system prompt is actually quite
interesting. For example, uh claude will
actually tell the model to the claw that
MD file should be followed unless it's
not relevant, in which case don't follow
it.
>> Yeah, that was a fun one.
>> Uh is this the one?
>> Sorry. Yeah. So, this is one of the
traces. I have to scroll over cuz I did
a search.
>> Just copy the line and then we can just
JSON format it.
>> Well, so what I wanted to show you is
basically part of what's in your context
window, right? So, the thing is a list
of messages and the tools get listed in
is you have your bash tool, you have
your glob tool, you have your GP tool.
So there's all these built-in tools,
right? And then you'll also have any MCP
tools that you add in. And so let's see
if I have any of these in here. So yeah,
here's the linear MCP tools. So you have
a bunch of JSON and schemas that explain
to the model how to use these different
tools. And so like this doesn't get
injected in the context window.
>> Pause for a second there.
>> Yeah.
>> I want you guys to take a look at this.
See the name? The name is MCP linear
list cycles. Like it's not just that
you're injecting stuff into the model,
you're also injecting random names that
Claude has to use to like differentiate
stuff to pass it into the model. Like
why does a model care that this thing is
called MCP linear list ticket? Like if I
only have one thing for getting
documents and it's purely linear, I
could just call this get document and
it's going to work effectively very very
similarly. In fact, they'll probably
work better because again, it's it's not
about these small naming differences are
exactly why Enthropic had to rename
their tool to general purpose away from
a broader
um away from a broader like subtask
because the names really make a huge
difference in accuracy.
>> Well, and just just to just to like
clear that up also like the the if we
look for we can find the task tool here.
Um, if my search
>> you want to just copy this and paste it
into a JSON prettier.
>> Uh, no. The problem is is that this
proxy logged things with um,
this proxy logged things with a
serialized JSON thing.
>> That's okay. You can just unserialize
the JSON if you copy and paste it. If
you I'll send you the website.
>> No, no, no. Um,
just hang on. There we go. So the task
tool has a prompt and a description
right now, but in a newer version of
Claude, they added like sub agents with
names. And so general purpose is the
default name for the task tool in newer
versions of cloud code. And this this
this shell this um this prompt is a
little old. Um so I just want to clear
that up. There's a general purpose sub
agent that is to differentiate from any
custom sub aents that you might have.
But in the because in the old world
there was just task and there was no a
there was no name parameter in here.
Um but I want to get back on track here.
So we have all the built-in tools like
bash gp glob. Um we have then the uh mcp
tools that you might add right and I'm
just going to go through a couple
examples with claude. So this is like
linear list issues. And we're going to
do a really simple example today, which
is essentially around um let's go find
it. Um what's the difference between
using a CLI to talk to linear to get an
issue versus oh no, this is what I get
for writing my readmemes in in Neovim
and not setting up actually a bunch of
good neoim plugins.
Um, so we're going to look at um just a
really simple cloud command here. Um,
because you can actually without even
doing the proxy stuff.
You can um
you can see the output and the tokens
used and you can use that to count the
tokens. Embedded in these messages is
basically something that looks like
this. And so what we care about the most
is cache creation input tokens. And if
we sum those up over a user uh over a
session, then we can get kind of a clear
picture of how many tokens were used in
that session. There's a little script in
here um that will uh actually parse this
output and make it useful. Um so you can
steal this and use it. It's really quite
simple. Um, but we have our initial our
our assistant message and we created
6,000 tokens here and then it read that
file and then it's going to write that
file and so each one of these is some n
number of tokens that is the actual like
JSON of the tool call. Does that make
sense? By Bob questions?
Yeah. Okay, cool. So, um, you can also
do something cool where if you run the
exact same thing again, you will
actually see that this is like this is
not an episode about caching. We went
really deep on caching when we went
through the manice paper, but if you use
the exact same user message and the same
set of allowed tools, then you're
actually using the cache the whole way
through. All of these calls are exactly
the same. And so we're not actually
writing any new tokens to the cache,
which is both cheaper and faster. Um,
but if you bust the cache by changing
the user message, you can see a slightly
different output. So, because I changed
it from write food to bar.txt txt to
please write fudabar.txt.
Everything that comes after my user
message is recomputed. And so it didn't
do all 6,000 because the cloud system
message is still the same and the
cloudmd is still the same. But somewhere
in here, I think that what happens is
the user message comes in before the
tools and stuff. I don't know exactly
the mechanics of it. We can go look at
it. But um the idea is if you only
change parts of it, then you get to
reuse parts of the cache. Um cool. Does
that make sense so far? Um, so now what
I'm going to do is I have here um the
MCP linear thing. Um, so this is just a
simple MCP config to add linear to our
app.
Um, and so I'm going to run this one
now, too. Oops, not that. And then I'm
going to pop back to the whiteboard in a
second. Um, but we'll see here is we're
going to add way more tokens to the
context window. Yeah. So there's 18,000.
the difference between linear and
nonlinear is about 12,000 extra tokens.
And so if you think about your total
context window, um
what we talk about a lot is trying to
keep it below like 40% usage. And so
rather than like having Claude work for
a long time back and forth, we just say
like have Claude do one thing, have the
agent do one thing, get it right, and
then start over with a fresh context
window and have it work on the next
thing. Um, and so that means that even
though this entire context window is,
you know, 200k tokens minus 32k input
tokens, which means you get a total of
like
168k
um to work with. So 12,000 tokens,
let's see, is 7% of your context window.
It's not crazy, but if you go start
putting
like six different MCPs in there,
um, you are eating up, you know, a
fourth of and like you're already
basically like your system prompt and
your cloud MD is
is what? So, we added 12 and then we
have like 6K in the base. That's
assuming you have like a tiny cloud MD,
right?
This is this is very small right now.
Um, and this is telling it to use the
MCP tools for linear. Um, and so when we
I'm gonna skip the CLI part for a sec.
We'll just do this one. Um, so I'm gonna
ask it to fetch an issue
um, from linear and we'll see how many
tokens that count that takes. Actually,
I haven't tested this part. Um,
I'm going to check the Are there any
questions in the chat while we're going
through this?
>> We've got one that I really like.
>> Let's do it.
>> Which is,
>> what are these extra tokens like? where
do these 18,000 tokens come from? And I
think the best way to actually show that
off is can you just pull up the JSON
right there?
Um, can you open the JSON really quick?
The linear JSON, the linear um thing
that you pass in.
>> Yeah. And we'll actually pull it up and
I'll show you how to use the NP MCP
inspector. Let me just because we can
also look here.
>> Yeah, but I want to show just the JSON
really fast. uh if you're able to just
>> So if we look in
you want to see the JSON like the actual
request
>> the No, no, I want to see the linear MCP
file.
>> Oh, okay.
>> Yeah, cool.
>> MCP linear.json. Exactly. Uh and then
can you open that file, the MCP linear
SSC on the browser?
>> Um no, but I can do you one better. Uh
inspector. Let's see what this does. Uh
I assume this is going to have a nice
little UI on top of the
>> Exactly. Yeah. This is how you can So we
can connect here and see.
>> Do you just want to open the browser?
It'll be
just to open it really fast. Yeah.
>> Oh, it's SSE not. There we go. So you
can list out the tools. So there are
names and descriptions and everything
you see here is being passed into the
model to tell it how to use these tools.
So the description of every field, the
description of every method, and the
name of every method. And there's just a
lot of these. And some of them have very
complex um like yeah, list teams has all
of these like sorting and filter params.
So every single word in here is a token.
Is that kind of what you're looking for?
>> Exactly. So like when when we got asked
this question uh about like where what
are all these tools actually coming
from? Like the problem is
unlike unlike a website where like every
single div you put in really doesn't
make it to the user, it does make it to
the browser. And when you render every
div, you could have like five divs le
nested with each other and the browser
will render it and it'll look the same.
If you have a really really really
really old computer, having like 50 divs
nested will be worse than simply having
a single that will be much worse than
having a single div if you don't need
it. That said, from an end user
perspective on today's computers, it
doesn't matter. But today,
when you're doing this with an LLM,
every single word you put into that MCP
server is literally making it to the LM.
And unlike browsers, as of right now,
these models are not good enough. You
got to forget the slashes. This is why
we use text highlighting and why we use
a programming language.
>> No, no, we're using a whiteboard today
by Bob. It's going to be fine.
>> Yeah. But like the point here is like
from a from an end user perspective,
this white this this thing doesn't
matter. Like who cares that this thing
has uh five divs? No one. But in the
world of an MCP where you have five 50
redundant words, it's actually hurting
your performance because the model has
to actually look at it and it has to do
computation to decide what that that
word is actually irrelevant to this
request. It's not merely So if you go
back,
>> you want to go to the inspector.
>> In this case, all I wanted to do was
just get an edge ticket. Why do I have
to know that I have to list teams? It's
totally useless information.
>> And you can you can tune this a little
bit, right? Especially with sub agents,
you can like disallow or allow certain
tools. Um, and then you're going to get
less in the context window. Um,
>> but that's all manual. You can't
actually do it.
>> You can't actually disallow tools.
>> I think in sub agents it will not be
shown to the model if if you put it in
disallow tools.
>> So we can actually test this.
>> You have to pass that in though. That's
a
>> Yeah, you have to you I mean you have to
engineer it. You have to say, okay, like
here's my context window. If I want to
save 1% so I can get, you know, 1%
better performance, then I'm going to
only put in this four MCP tools from
linear that I use and I'm going to like
hide all the other ones. But you have to
understand how context windows work. You
have to end this. This is the
engineering part.
>> Exactly. And I think this is really
where the MCP versus bash debate gets to
really get started, which is that if you
are using MCP, the problem is you don't
get to control exactly what bits make it
into your context window or it is at
least very difficult to control what
bits make it into your context window.
>> Yeah.
>> On the other hand, if you're using bash,
you now live in this world where you
have to kind of reinvent everything or
the model has to reinvent everything. So
like to make to make a linear request,
it has to do a curl on the linear API
and the model is trained on it and it
knows what the linear URLs are, then
great. But if it's not trained on it,
now you live in this world where you
have to run multiple iteration loops to
go figure out what that is. And I think
that's really the duality of this whole
debate of like which side do you prefer
on? Do you prefer on the model becoming
less accurate because you're bloating it
up or do you prefer on the model being
less accurate because it doesn't know
how to use the thing you wanted to use?
And this is kind of the chart you kind
of like to draw a lot, which is like do
you want, you know, the the like curves,
right? Is like how much engineering
effort do you want to put into this? Um,
it's sort of like for low effort, you
can get something like this.
Oh my god, I'm so bad at drawing with a
trackpad. And then if you want to do a
little bit more engineering effort, you
can kind of like collapse this in and
narrow the range of potential outputs or
narrow the range of performance. I don't
know if that's uh that's that's how
you're thinking about it.
>> Yeah. Um the only caveat is you usually
draw it with a slightly higher peak in
the middle because if you're narrowing
it, you're usually doing it because you
want a better outcome. So you're getting
way better outcomes for the care
>> area of the domain you care about versus
more generalized outcome in more
domains. And both can have pros and
cons.
>> Yeah. Exactly. If you take away half the
linear tools, you can't do as much stuff
on linear. But if you only want to do
those things, then yeah, engineer it and
just focus on the things you want to
focus on.
>> Exactly. So it's not so I would say like
the bait and conclusion that I don't
know about your conclusion, Dex, but
like the main conclusion that I've had
about MCP
>> is I am very happy to use MCP stuff that
I have written.
I'm very unhappy to use stuff MCP stuff
that other people have written because
when I write it, I know where it is. I
know where the code lives and I can go
edit it myself to make it actually not
hurt the prompt or not hurt the coding
agent.
>> But if I use someone else's stuff, then
I have like can you pull up the GitHub
MCP just to like really make or like
Joff's uh Jeff's uh blog post on this?
>> Yeah. What was the one? um
>> G Huntley and I think he talks about
like uh email if we can't find it just
pull up the MCP for it. Just
>> put the link in the chat.
>> Yeah, if someone has a chat link, just
post it in there. But like just look up
the GitHub MCP server and
>> drop that one in the inspector.
>> I hate that this thing doesn't tell me
how to use it.
>> So, put that over into the uh inspector
if you have it. And I just want to like
get people an idea for like how insane
this MCP is. And like if anyone's using
MTP with get this GitHub uh I would be
surprised if it worked in in any modly
complex task MCP.
>> Yeah, we'll try this one. This is like
the dynamic client registration thing.
Um we can try just doing this.
>> Does it work? Okay.
>> Does not support I can just look up the
and I think it has like the it has the
actual prompt in here really fast that
you can go see. Um I mean if you just go
down and just let go just go down the
GitHub. You're going to see it right
here. Go to the GitHub. I'll show you
what it is and just scroll down.
>> Just let's just look at these tool
configurations. Let's just look at how
many they have first.
>> God,
>> like look at this stuff.
>> Yeah,
>> we're giving it and this is just the
docs. This isn't even like the MCP
format. I promise you the actual MCP is
not this short.
>> It's going to be longer than this. And
like well, no wonder you just spent 60k
tokens of your context window doing
this. And if you're using 128k to model
by chance and you're not using one of
the 1 million context windows, well,
duh. it's not working. You just use half
your context window just to describe it
how to use the GitHub.
>> So, and it looks like they do have flags
for hiding and removing stuff. So, you
wouldn't even have to wrap this. But,
like if you if you if you care and you
only want to work with issues, then you
can probably trim it down quite a bit.
>> That's if you're running the GitHub MCP
on your own. That's only if you're
running the GitHub MCP server on your
own. If you're using
>> When would you not be When would you not
be running it on your own? or you might
be using like an MCP remote and using
someone else's GitHub server.
And this also requires you to know ahead
of time what your MCP services are. So
like let's let's imagine we're in a
world where
>> I'm jump back to the whiteboard.
>> Yeah, I'm running a bunch of GitHub
commands. Sometimes I get commit,
sometimes I get pull, sometimes I um
sometimes I track issues, I do various
things. Now I have to spin up a
different GitHub MTP for every single
instance that I want to go call the
model on. It basically boils down to
either me prescribing everything ahead
of time or me somehow training the model
to do this. And I think the very
interesting point that Joff made was
like or Jeff made was like instead of um
instead of actually passing in the
GitHub MCP, you can just use the GH CLI
which the model is very very well
trained on. You don't need an MCP in
this scenario because if you ask like I
don't know just ask Claude to like dump
out the GH command for like
>> Yep.
>> getting a specific issue. There you go.
>> Using GH. Yeah.
>> I mean this is going to work. I
guarantee you it's going to oneshot this
on the first try and you're not going to
have any issues.
>> Exactly. And I don't know what model
you're using.
>> It's like cool. Here's this is Opus. But
like it doesn't matter. Sonic canes
one-shot this too. And so
>> so so what I want to get into in the
time we have left and then we'll make
time for questions is basically like how
do you get around this and how do you
engineer around this and basically what
we've done at human layer is we've
written our own kind of wrapper around
the linear CLI that lets us it's not
only that it's not an MCP it's just a
CLI because bash is pretty good when
you're and if you're using a coding
agent you don't really need more um but
basically this lets you control every
token that comes out and so we are using
um
we are using basically like markdown.
We're pulling out the fields that we
care about and then we're just pulling
the markdown. And then if you want to
get the comments, you just have another
flag for getting the comments. And that
all happens outside of the model versus
if uh so yeah, here's a bunch of
comments on this issue. This happens to
have been open for a while, so there's a
lot of comments on it. Um but if you
want to expose this stuff to the model,
I mean, this is pretty this is pretty
dense. And so I might say like, you
know, tell the model to fetch it into
like a ticket.md and then it can read it
incrementally or whatever it is. But
this is so much more flexible because
you're not forced to push the inputs and
outputs through your model's context
window. The model can just use bash and
stream everything into a file and then
read the file incrementally. You have it
there. You don't have to call it again
uh if you don't want to. Um,
and so what this means is like if we go
and we run this with our token counter,
we can kind of compare the like I want
to just see how this works, but is like
um if we ask it to do I'm just going to
do missions cuz I'm not convinced that
the actual uh the white labeling of MCPS
is working as I expect it to. But um we
can grab this one and say fetch the
issue and all comments and we'll see the
the huge difference in token usage
between using the MCPS and going back
and forth versus um versus just uh I'll
run another one over here which is um we
can take there's like another claude MD
linear CLI into cloudMD. And so instead
of having a [__] ton of MCP tools, we
have this really tight, very small, very
token efficient description of like
here's how to fetch an issue, here's how
to fetch it with comments. And instead
of 12,000 tokens, this is probably like
a max 100 tokens of like here's the
tools and here's how to use them. Um,
and so let's see. This was 24,000 tokens
to fetch it. I think it actually
probably used the bash tool. Um, it
didn't even use the linear MCPS. Um,
damn. All right, we'll have to post uh
we'll get the prompt right and we'll
we'll post it up afterwards. Um, but if
we do it this way and we do the same
thing and we just take out the linear
MCPS and we have this new cloud MD that
says use the CLI,
um, we should see far less tokens get
used in the cache creation.
So like uh Dax, what would you say is
like the general summary that you would
tell people here? Like what what is like
the general takeaway is like when should
someone use MCP in your mind? Um it's
again it's like if you don't if you
don't know how to integrate the API or
you don't want to or you don't have the
time or you want to do an experiment
then like yes you can totally just use
the MCP play with it but then if you're
using something all day in your workflow
and like it's the same thing we tal
about we talked about last time in this
like hierarchy of leverage right is like
the more something impacts your workflow
the more you should care about it. And
so like I put your MCP tools somewhere
down here. If everybody on your team is
going to be using something every day as
part of their workflow, then it makes
sense to engineer it because if you make
it 1% better and use, you know, instead
of using 2% of the context window, use
1% or instead of using 7% of the context
window, you use 1%. Then that's going to
have massive campa cascading impacts
across your whole team. If you're like,
let me play with this and see if this
works, then yeah, just use the MCP
because it's off the shelf and it just
works. It's the same thing as like if
you were going to pull an npm package
for, you know, a sorting algorithm and
then you're like, okay, this is actually
the core most important loop in our
code. So, we need to write our own
version of it because algorithms is a
bad example because there's like a
specific reference implementation, but
something performance sensitive that's
going to be in a really tight loop, then
that's when you need to think about uh
spending more time optimizing it. And
this is what we talk about all the time,
right? Vib, your example is like, yeah,
use 03 to solve the problem until it's
either too slow or too expensive and
then go figure out whatever prompt is
going to help you use GPT 40 mini to do
the same work with almost as good
results, right?
>> Yeah, I think it's the same thing
actually. I echo that 100%. Like, and
for me candidly, I haven't really I
found it more work to go dig into MCPS
than to just like write a bash script
because like cloud code will just turn
out a bash script real fast for almost
everything I want to do
and like the MCP becomes more overhead
because I have to go figure out how to
go set it up and learn it really fast
and when it doesn't work, debugging
becomes a problem for me. Um, so at
least whenever I have tried, I found the
debugging loop is bad enough that I
found it just useful to just start with
bash by default or like custom scripts
whenever I go do this. Um, and I
actually don't have any MCPS installed
on my on any agent that I use
personally.
>> Well, and it it depends what you're
doing, right? If you on the runtime, if
it's a coding assistant and you can
dynamically expand the runtime as you
need new things, then yes, of course,
why would you go use something off the
shelf if you know exactly what you want
and you know enough to review the
scripts and make sure that it's correct.
I think where MCP really really shines
is in allowing people who don't have the
will or the time to extend existing
software. So, if you have like your
cursor window here,
uh, and like I know how to use cursor,
or maybe it's like claw desktop or
whatever it is, um, and I want to just
[__] connect this to all my stuff,
but I'm not, you know, a super I don't
know why I chose to do a dark mode theme
here.
>> If I'm not comfortable in code, then
it's going to be really annoying for me
to go connect that all the way down
through.
>> Uh, exactly. Steve made a good point.
Like if you're APIs that you don't know
very well or like if you're not familiar
if you don't feel comfortable with like
software as much because like AI has
enabled you to go explore software in a
way that you couldn't then it's really
good. Uh the browser use MCP sounds
really interesting. I haven't personally
tried it. Uh people have tried
playright. um John's saying in the chat.
Um so I do like the premise of that and
then like I found that like
personally it's just like
I don't know my opinion is just like all
this stuff while it's nice is just it
slows you down unless you have a good
developer loop. If the thing you're
doing is writing code then the thing
that matters the most is how fast can
you know the code is working or not
working. And if you're stuck debugging
the thing that is generating the code
for you, that is a much slower iteration
loop than actually stuck debugging the
actual code itself.
>> Yeah, I like that. Um, cool. What other
questions?
>> Um, have we got questions for people
today? Dex, what I'd love to do with
like the remainder of the time is
actually like let's look at the plot
system prompt while we go while I pull
up questions. I'm going to show this.
>> We got a question. What are the best
resources to build MCP or something like
uh Zapier?
To be honest, uh that problem is not as
hard as you might suspect. Uh in order
to go build that out, there's actually a
small little piece of code that we have
in our past examples. Let me share my
screen. I'll show you. Um and I'll show
you guys where that example is so you
can take a look at it. Share screen.
Screen. Cool. So, in one of our past uh
episodes, we talked about this
MCP. We talked about Oh. Oh, the like
how to select from a thousand MCP tools.
>> Exactly.
One of these is this one. I don't know
which one it is. Oh, right here.
>> Um, and we actually talked about this
and we actually have code samples of
actually how to go run this. It turns
out writing an MCP loop is actually
pretty straightforward. You just need a
way to turn open API specs into prompts
and then a way to receive those prompts
and feed it back in to the open API
spec. So when Dex was showing the
example where like the linear tool was
named MCP_linear
list uh issues that's simply because a
clawed code CLI needs a way to remap
like when the LM selects that tool they
need a way to remap and pick that tool
and actually execute it through the MCP
agent. So like the code you end up
writing
actually ends up looking something like
this. I'll just write a quick little
pseudo code here. Um, which ends up
being like let agent equals all
>> I think. Do you mean to be sharing your
editor?
>> Oh, I'm not sharing the right screen.
Okay, I'm sharing another screen now.
response equals like call agent user
message tools and tools has to be like
generate uh load mcp file
>> mcp you connect to the server and then
you talk to it and you get its list of
tools and then you pass that into your
call and that's all that's happening
>> it's an open API spec so all you're
doing is parsing that turning into some
data model and most people can read JSON
and turn it from one JSON to another
JSON so you go do that uh and then you
just say like for tool in response
um um if done if uh response
else what you do is like you just say
like
tools do uh tools.lookup lookup tool
name or something and then like run uh
state append
result
and then you just put this in a while.
That's all an MCP tool call is. You load
your tools from an a from a file. You
have some initial state which is a user
message. Then you call the agent with or
call an LM with a bunch of tools and the
state passed in. Then you check if your
tool indicates you're done. Return the
message to the model somehow. Otherwise,
you in your tools registration, you look
up the name that the model selected and
you pass it to the you pass in the
parameters of the model selected and you
run it and then you get the result pass
to the state and keep on running this in
a while loop until you're actually done.
So hopefully harsh that answers your
question of how someone would go and
build this out along the way.
>> Yeah, this is uh this is a good thing to
just kind of jam into your brain is like
>> this is how agents work. If you haven't
written this while loop, write this
while loop. Like literally don't use a
framework. Just like write the while
loop. If you're curious how to do it, we
have a bunch of examples in our podcast
of how to go do it. And but like this is
like the crux of how models agents work.
>> Okay. I have more fun context window
stuff if you want to pop back over.
>> Yeah, I'll stop screen sharing. Uh I'm
going to go catch up with other
questions while you go do that.
>> Cool. Um, so we did someone did share uh
Jeff's article. This is definitely worth
a read. And he just did a talk that I
posted on Twitter recently. Um, but it's
basically like a tool is just a
description of what the fields are and
what they are. Um, and so you can figure
out what the tool is and all the models
have their own way of serializing tools
into the model and especially the closed
platforms, it's kind of like you don't
get good visibility into it, but you can
count the tokens and every single like
word in your tool description or your
argument description uh matters to the
model. And so like when Reddit comes up
and says like, "Hey, we must have these
MCP servers if you're going to work."
And then you can look and you say,
"Okay, the GitHub MCP server 60,000
tokens. Memory MCP 10,000 tokens." Like
you put all these in there and this is
literally straight from Jeff's talk. Uh
but it's like you put all these in there
and you're literally starting at 100,000
context usage. You're using all of your
like useful part of the context window
because again remember like your context
window. This is like the the money
section of your context window. This is
where you're going to get good work
done. Everything goes downhill after
here. And so if you're starting your
work with your first user message at
like 60% context window usage, you are
never ever ever going to get good
results from cloud code. like maybe for
simple stuff, maybe in like really
simple code bases or or like new like
new projects you can get it to do stuff,
but if you load in 50 MCP tools, like
it's all about like yes, cloud makes it
easy to just get going, but if you don't
understand what's happening under the
hood, then you are going to have bad
results. Um, and so understanding this
stuff and understanding like yes, the
long context models can do needle in a
haystack really well, but most of the
general performance drops off pretty
quickly as you add more tokens. Um, oh,
cool. And Een has a spreadsheet of which
of these and how much how many tokens
they put in.
>> They just take a large amount. Um, on a
very actually Alexander asked a great
question. It's it's related but not uh
and I think in a way that Alexander
probably unex did not expect which is
>> how do you deal with thoughts on images
in prompts or other things that are
going on? Um, and I have a lot of
opinions on this person. I'm sure Dex
does too. Um,
>> yeah. But I'm going to take over the
screen decks.
Uh share the screen. And funnily enough,
we actually talked about this in not too
long ago, which is when we talked about
um uh multimodal stuff.
>> Yeah.
>> The fact is like images can sometimes
take up more tokens to describe what you
want and sometimes less tokens to
describe what you want. It really
varies, but sometimes it can be
incredibly powerful. If you're doing web
development, an image is likely going to
help describe the mistake that you made
to the model way better than a visual
will. If it's a very small thing, uh
words will probably just do good enough.
But like if it's a very complex thing
like move this thing over here, the
image will
>> or like
>> if you really don't understand web
development and you can't like if you
know how CSS works and you're like, oh,
we need to add padding to that node,
then you can say that. But if you don't
know how to explain that to a model
because you don't know the difference
between margin and padding, which is me,
then yeah, give it the picture and it'll
be like, "Oh, I need more padding."
>> Exactly. And I think like it it's really
uh a nuance. Uh but honestly,
images work really well. People that
aren't using I I have a I might have
this thing running. It's like check this
out. Like this is a straightup image off
the model. It generally works off the
bat. to like boom phone call extract and
this is straight up live running off the
model and models are really really good
at image processing. All right. And
there you go. And it just pulls stuff
out. Um like if you're not using models
for image processing you're you're
hurting yourself. Go do that.
>> Yeah.
>> Um at least in my opinion.
>> Yeah. Um all right. All right, I got one
more thing on context windows um which
is that cloud system prompt stuff and
this is what you can figure out by
actually like going through the traces
itself because this won't come out in
the claw JSON output lines um but like
you may have stuff that always goes in
your context window like but you should
know that in your cloud MD it is
injected with a very specific message so
whatever you put in your cloud MD it
will be added at the very end you will
get this thing which is basically like
do not pay attention to anything in
clawet MD unless it's super relevant.
And most of the time you should ignore
what's in here, which is why I don't
know if you found you put certain things
in cloud MD like always run the tests
after making a change and it kind of
only does it like 10% of the time. This
is why and I think this is a product
decision from anthropic and I understand
why they did this. It's probably because
most people don't know how to write a
good claude MD and in many cases over
steering the model is actually more
harmful than understeering it because
the model has emergent capabilities and
so like you'd rather deemphasize the
inputs from an unskilled prompter than
like risk that they basically just tank
the performance by having a a rogue
sentence and claw MD that ruins
everything.
>> Exactly. That's why they have this and
it makes sense. But like if you're a
skilled prompter, it's hurting you.
>> Yeah. And so this is why actually like
you should know what's in your context
window. And what I do is I actually
craft the context window. So all of my
instructions, I don't put them in
cloudmd. They're actually dynamic based
on the files in the repo. Um because
context engineering is about blending
deterministic and non-deterministic
code. This is what we always talk about
like where do you use the LMS, where do
you not? And so I actually have a slash
command in one of our repos. I think we
talked about this on the cloud for
non-Cloud like usages, but there's a
/CTX that basically says run this make
task and then run this make task and
then do whatever the user said. And so
it's like if I run /ctx with some
specific instructions, the first thing
it's going to do is run this print
context, which is literally just going
to cat out the contents of a bunch of
files that explains. We use this to like
run the company and run our CRM and
stuff like this. And so it's going to
cat out a bunch of files that show,
okay, here's what we've been talking
about recently. here's our key metrics,
here's the last couple investor updates,
things like this. Um, and so this is
crafting your context window. You're
telling the model the first thing you do
is you like output these things. And
it's dynamic, right? You could put it in
a file and just have it output it. But
what I really want is I just want to
take the top 200 lines of these like
couple files. And then you can also like
write code to generate the tree. And so
like we have a file tree here that is
basically just like here's every single
file that is interesting to you that is
like sliced and filtered based on the
markdown. We use like markdown front
matter a lot. So this is a file in our
CRM. And so it's got a bunch of like
fields at the top that you can parse for
slicing and dicing. Um and then it's and
then we can just like okay the things
that match the filter print the file
name and the summary from the file
itself. And so like this is again like
crafting your context window. This is
the bigger picture and like this is the
thing that even as the models get
smarter, even as the coding agents
change, like as long as we're still on
like transformer-based LLM technology
and we don't have any like huge
breakthroughs, this will matter for a
while.
>> Yeah. That said, I'll I'll push one
counterpoint there uh really fast
because I do agree with everything that
says, which is the models are changing
at a rate that I personally did not
predict. So it's possible that today's
context limit is around like 40 60%
according to Dex in terms of how good it
is. It might be tomorrow's model is like
good at 60% or 80%. So like what I find
is useful is I just try and push the
model like sometimes I'll just toss in a
bunch of context and just see how well
it deals and like sometimes it works,
sometimes it doesn't. So like while it's
good to have a general rule of thumb,
what I find is it is definitely good to
always texture yourself as well. And
thanks for the feed by the way John.
Thanks for the feedback. We'll fix the
audio next time and get it working. Not
sure why my audio is softer than someone
else's, but just like keep on pushing
the model to their limits. Push in 100k
tokens and see if it works and does what
you want. Push in easy tasks, push in
hard tasks, and just see what it works.
>> Talking about models evolving as
rapidly, do you still use SAP in
production instead of function calls?
>> Um, everyone that uses BAML does. Um,
and it works pretty well. It actually we
tested it on GPD5. We have better
performance on tool calling on GT5 as
well. And I think it just go boils down
to the same basics is like
describing the tool to the model just
gives you better results in general and
not requiring JSON will generally always
give you better results.
>> What is SAP?
>> Um little off topic uh but sure
uh what is SAP for those of you that
don't know? Well, I'll show you guys
really fast. um screen. I will share a
browser window or a cursor window.
What's the next question, Dax, while I
pull up this?
>> Um kind of a side note. Is BAML likely
to support hotel at any point? I can
take this one. Uh actually, maybe I
shouldn't.
Uh I have hacked BAML by you could
there's like a modular API where you can
separate the request and response. And
if you hang on to the Bambble Discord,
there's a bunch of people who have
gotten it to go to any because it's just
key value pairs. You can send it
anywhere.
>> Yeah. Um what is what is SAP? Um SAP is
this algorithm that we have that says
when you ask a model, in this case, turn
an image or a string into a ré data
model which is described like this. SAP
is this really really cool algorithm
that we have that says no matter what
the model does, it will work. So in this
case, I put back JSON and we got to
ignore it. But we can go further and say
no quotes around keys. So like my prompt
is literally this really really basic
thing. Add three reasons why this resume
is a good fit. And I just changed the
prompt from the previous. I'm still
using the John Doe example. But now when
I go run it, well the model didn't
listen. I'm using GPT4 mini. But this
thing is not valid JSON at all. It has
no quotation marks. It kind of has
nothing. But we still pulled out the
right data. So, our parser is kind of
like a
uh you can think of it as a um SAP on
steroids or JSON.parse on steroids is
kind of like how I would think about it.
>> Oh, so many DSPI questions. We talked
about this a couple week weeks ago um
about people combining DSP's approach
with BAML's schema line parser approach
and they actually work best when you put
them together which is exciting.
Thanks for the abort controller. Yeah,
that was a fun project we did. Um,
>> as uh it started off as a bit and then
we decided to see how much how much code
we could ship in one day. Uh, and uh, I
actually got to architect the Golang
side of that. Um, because Claude was bad
at fetching data from the internet about
how to do idiomatic cancellation in Go.
So thankfully I spent five years
building that at replicated.
>> Um,
>> sorry, my dog went bonkers cuz uh,
someone came into my house. You are all
good. People are talking about how great
the abort controller is. I think I think
I think uh any final questions otherwise
we will wrap it up and uh as always we
will post the code and the recordings
and uh the next event on Luma within uh
about 24 hours.
>> Um Javier's got a question. Does someone
here know why the Gemini streaming model
outputs sentence chunks uh but word
chunks?
Uh oh. Well, one thing to note about how
to how streaming works under the hood is
the model is always streaming, the model
only generates one token at a time.
There's no way to make the model
generate two tokens or skip towards
that. Um, what ends up happening is
while the model is always streaming, the
API provider that you're using chooses
how many tokens to send you at any given
stream time.
>> Their prerogative.
>> So unless you own the model, you can't
guarantee when you get it. OpenAI may
currently be giving you one token at a
time. I know sometimes they give me two
or three. It really varies. Sometimes
they give you 10. It varies. Like I
would not build any any amount of
reliability ever in your application.
That depends on getting one token at a
time. It would be a bad bet to make.
>> Yep.
>> Sick.
>> I think there's one more a couple more
questions. Do we see any? Uh did you
give your opinions on DS5?
I was talking about we talked about I
forget which episode it is. We will find
it and put it in the show notes, but we
did talk about someone posted a study
where it's actually the the best the
best way to do this is to combine BAML
and DSPI together.
>> Yeah, I think the idea of DSPI
personally is really interesting. I view
DSP as like, oh, we don't actually want
to go write the prompts. Uh maybe we can
have something else autogenerate the
prompts. I think that concept is
actually really fascinating, but I think
we're at depth. I think you made a tweet
about this. It's just like we're in the
early eras of how programming LMS works
and like the early C compilers were just
not that good. Like they they just
weren't that good cuz they didn't know
what kinds of things people wanted to
write in C. So they couldn't possibly
optimize very well. You need some bake
time to make these sort of optimizers
really really good. Um, and sometimes a
lot of this stuff is just like like for
example, MCP is this attempt for for
writing this optimized tech. In theory,
linear could sit down and optimize the
heck out of the linear API for accuracy
and like make it really like make the
words perfect. And in that theoretical
world, we should all use a linear MCP
because it is the best way to interface
with the model because the linear team
owns that responsibility and optimizes
the heck out of it. In practice,
you end up in a world where it's not
that good and that someone just ships
something really really fast and it like
looks like it works but doesn't actually
work.
>> Well, and I don't want to talk about it
in terms of like quality or
craftsmanship even. I think it's the
same as that like system message in
Claude MD where it's like they kind of
have to optimize for like what's what's
80% of the value for everybody because
they know the people who really care
about every single token can always go
do it themselves but I think the goal is
like how do you give the most value to
the broadest number of people
>> exactly and like when I when I really
think about this it's like I just don't
think prompts per like personally my
opinion is I don't think prompts are in
a world where 80% is good enough
>> because they're running it's like it's
like CSS stuff like no one uses
Bootstrap anymore because Bootstrap was
80% CSS.
>> It's like it gets you the website but
like you can't ever use Bootstrap as
your design system unless you're Twitter
and that is your actual design system
because it doesn't it's not customizable
enough. It's not maintainable. So then
you end up using Shad CN because Shaden
lets you as a developer have a good
starting point but you get to own
everything and edit it yourself. I think
the premise that you will never want to
read and write the you will never want
to read the prompt and edit the prompt
manually is fundamentally flawed. I
think at least for the at least for the
foreseeable future the next and by that
I mean like the next 12 to 18 months
is the furthest I would say you will
want to see the prompt and you might
want to have something write the first
version of the prompt but likely you'll
want to hand tune it and at to some
degree to some or at least have
visibility into what it is in a useful
and editable way just like we have
wanted that with CSS and it took us
about like 20 years to make that
conclusion about CSS that like hey we
don't want like a framework that lives
somewhere in npm node modules that is
write only uh that is
>> yeah we don't we don't want a component
library we want a a platform for
building component libraries that was
the right level of configurability
>> exactly and I think it's the same with
prompts personally I think like you
don't want a you don't want a prompt
library you want a way to write prompts
that you can edit and modify and do
whatever you want but have really good
jumping off points by default
>> and I talked to really really
opinionated designers. Just to like
continue this analogy a little bit more,
I talked to really good, really
opinionated designers who care about
every single pixel on the page and they
love shad CN because they can apply
every single style they want to every
component and be guaranteed that it's
customized and they don't have to reach
through some like artificial interface
which is like like Bootstrap has an
interface to it. There's things you can
do with Bootstrap and there's things you
can't do. Whereas what Shad Cian gets
you is the entire spectrum, the entire
solution space of every single class you
could apply is available to you. It's
clean and nice via Tailwind and you have
sane defaults. But if you want to change
something, there's no like reading the
docs of like, okay, how do I tell
Bootstrap to apply padding to a
component like this? You just look at it
and you open the box and you set the
padding. And I think the same is true
for prompts right now. And the same is
true for agents. Like a good agent
framework will absolutely
like give you the ability to reach into
the box and customize everything
>> without having to read.
>> I think that point about reading docs is
really important. I think Ariel as a
good question is like oh does that mean
like DSP changed that focus? I think DSP
does a really really good job personally
of getting people to start thinking
about stuff as input output pairs but
like at least when I worked in machine
learning it's really really hard to
actually build a golden eval data set in
practice. I think it's a good jumping
off point, but again, it just goes off
to like it's really good to make an
initial website with cloud code or
something else, but at some point you
always want that flexibility along the
way. In general, I think flexibility has
been really powerful. Um,
exactly. I think John made a good point
like generally frameworks have become
more flexible and opinionate versus
frameworks are becoming opinionated.
Like I I think opinions are like people
want to go in like people are becoming
more people want to build more things
not less things as time is going on.
Um Nathan you asked an interesting
question. What about context 7? I have
no idea what context 7 is so I can't uh
sadly answer that. Uh but um if you have
a tidbit on what it is and we can take a
look for next time. Uh Des is off on a
call. Uh I think he's running late. I
think we're ending the show today on
this. Uh, if someone has a um a couple
more questions, feel free to send them
over on the Discord. Our Discord is
generally open.
If you have um other things that you're
interested in chatting about, definitely
send us links on what we chat about.
This has been AI that works. If you want
to join the next episode, uh you can
subscribe to this calendar over here.
and we'll generally post uh new events
every Tuesday at um uh every Tuesday at
10 a.m. PST as per usual.
Look forward to the email, guys, and see
everyone